façon de diane bonjour merci de nous
accueillir dans votre loge vous êtes en
ce moment en tournée pour votre
excellent spectacle un soir de gala et
vous êtes aussi très connu pour être le
présentateur de la flamme
alors vous n'êtes pas dans la saison une
saison 2 de la flamme le flambeau
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas dans la saison 2 le dans le flambeau
bah si je suis dans le non
si je crois que je joue dedans je fais
le le le présentateur du grand c'est
jérôme commandeur
jérôme d'heure oui non
oui ça y est ça m'en viens jonathan ou
cohen c'est ça m'avait proposé
de
reprendre le rôle du présentateur dans
le flambeau que vous teniez dans la
flamme que je tenais dans la flamme
diana dit est ce que tu veux jouer dans
le flambeau et c'est vrai que il était
un peu trop tôt pour faire un choix
c'est à dire les serres qui m'a demandé
de choisir si je voulais ou pas joué
dans le flambeau oui et
et donc j'avais j'avais fait un choix
d'accorder un peu trop tôt avec des
pincettes pour faire un choix des
guillemets
plus des pincettes d'accord alors
vincent c'était quoi c'était une
question d'argent d'indisponibilité que
l'argent non géré ça j'étais très dispo
mais ça n'était pas très très bien payés
c'est à dire combien
symbolique
non
sens
[Musique]
on n'en saura pas plus merci beaucoup
vincent de dien on vous retrouve en
tournée évidemment et peut-être dans la
saison 2 de la flamme quand vous aurez
pris votre décision on espère et puis
peut-être la saison 3 mais là c'est
peut-être un peu trop tôt déjà carrément
trop dorée avant d'affirmer mon choix
est fait attendu vous voulez notre co
non c'est un peu gros